okay let's do another one
playing dylan u i am
played twice before
i'm gonna keep it up
maybe we'll have a another stafford
i had one staffer gambit the stream
at uh a bishop d3 game
okay so for gamma time
now this is risky because my opponent is
higher rated than
my other opponents and it's a 10 minute
game
and my phone is playing quickly so they
probably know kind of what to do
[Music]
but
i'm hopefully not afraid
yeah they're playing the
the so-called
refutation line
but i'm playing the so-called magical
line
wow f3
so
a lot of people are recommending bishop
f3 these days
so
[Music]
the f3 h4 and
i mean the engine will give like plus
four or five
in white's favor
which is a little bit concerning for
black okay i know bishop f4 is a good
move
or is it
wait let's
play this and see what happens
it's probably a good move
the goal in this position is to make
things wild
and create like enough chaos
so that white eventually goes wrong
there's a funny line knight e3 queen d3
bishop d4
pawn d4 queen d4 oh no my queen and then
i fork and win
the d4 pawn
the problem is i'm down a piece
and white probably has bishop c7 in the
end
i know i've had this position before too
and i don't remember
i don't remember the analysis
there's another idea to play this move
this move
hey buddy lover videos you are a really
smart person oh yeah quack
oh thank you charlie
quack back
um
i have knight h2
bunny move i don't think it works though
now knight shoot doesn't work at all
[Music]
i think 93 is the way to go
we'll see what happens from here
thank you mcbananas
and rallo welcome back
yeah i'm probably losing this or this at
some point
i'm also realizing in that line i was
calculating
so queen d3 takes takes takes takes
knight c2 if the key moves this way i
take and if takes i trap the rook in the
end
the problem is king d2
this should be very similar
so can i work any magic with knight g2
probably not
i'm starting to play around with the
leach s api and apparently the
recommended python project for
interacting with leaches is called
desert i guess i figured you should know
that
that's good to know thanks for sharing
heavenism
okay so knight g2
king f2
is kind of a problem
and if i save the bishop king takes i'm
looking at the line c or maybe bishop h3
first
king has to move here and then c5
maybe that's the way to go
oh no my knight
c5 is actually a typical resource in the
stafford
to try and break apart the solid
center um yeah i'll start with this
i don't pro i want to provoke the king
back to f2 so
there's no bishop f2
i was just looking at the funny line uh
king f2 c5 bishop e5 queen g6 rook g1
and then i take
and say oh no my queen
and i take here and win the white queen
and if queen e3 i take take and then
take on b2
and then win the rook
and make my queen reborn
i would still lose it but
i would win material in that line
so white has two legal moves
king g1 and king f2
king g1
so i guess white wants to play bishop f2
just defend
i just want to pressure the pawn ready
to castle
pin the pawn etc
i mean there's another funny line here
e5 and then oh no my queen
does that work
i think that would be playable
the king's a little bit awkward on g1
now because it's uh blocking in the rook
maybe more like hugging the rook
and if i can just open up the
[Music]
diagonal all i need to do is remove this
this and this and its meat
easier said than done
okay well now i'll take
i don't see how white defends now
because the diagonal is guaranteed to
open if bishop f2
also i should note earlier if white had
played bishop f2 i would have been
mating by force
and idea is still here to play queen g6
oh f3 is also hanging but
it's more important to open the diagonal
i think this will be an interesting game
to analyze because
it felt like i should have just been
down a piece but
somehow the counter play
was pretty rapid
i'm looking for other ways for white to
defend
i think it's too late e5 i take and take
and attack everything
and if bishop h3 i take
queen f2 i take take and then
eventually i'll have two queens
question from sanjay instead of bishop
f1 what about bishop e5
yeah bishop e5 i would have
i would have considered this move
or queen g6 first
again we can allies after the game
as guaranteed to to do things
i think i'll just leave the queen pinned
because if i take take
take white connects the rooks faster
and it's slightly cruel and unusual
[Music]
but it's also cool and unusual
so i'm winning the queen while making a
new queen
and i'll take with check
bishop f2 i
swing back with check
oh this bishop's hanging too
[Music]
okay
oh this is pleasant
i want to see how quickly i can check me
with two queens
because usually two queens are good to
check meeting
hawaii has a lot of things defending
i'll start with this
because free food
rook t1 coming
i can still legally castle both ways
except not this way yet because
bishop covers c8
wow bishop e1
okay so
i'm trying to win more material
there we go
thank you mr swift say my name
i just did
i beat you to it
queen a6
swinging all the way back
i really wanted to set up queensland
castling but
let's not fool around
got the queen battery aimed at the king
the queen batteries are pretty rare
uh thanks for the game
yeah my opponent actually like played a
really
probably challenging line
and the mistake was
what was white's mistake
it may have been king gen1
king g1 the position already like became
a bit difficult
although maybe there was bishop e5
bishop f1 is definitely not the
not the move to play
okay let's try and learn a thing or two
[Music]
oh white's still winning here according
to the engine
but this is how the stafford goes
like you try and put on so much pressure
that the opponent has to play very
accurately
thank you crosby 87 goat
gifting three
so wow plus five yeah king f2 is a bit
better
so what's the valuation i'm just curious
there's about four it's uh
yeah engine gives plus three
my opponent was prepared
um
oh i've had this position four times in
the past
oh once against the same opponent
we played in november
we played two months ago
what date did we play
whoa
cool graph
we played november 14th
where was i november 14th
i guess that was before dubai
you mentioned good habits earlier what
are your thoughts on alcohol and chess
performance do you know any gm's that
drink daily
uh i'm definitely not the person to ask
when it comes to that
i can address like
tea in chess performance
a tea helps me stay calm
also helps me like stay awake
i want like black tea or green tea
but yeah you might have to ask
someone else who
has more experience
but yeah generally
yeah you like health
health diet sleep exercise
they're all intertwined in
allowing you to play better chess
because like a big part of
playing good chess
is finding like your peak mental forum
and for a lot of players on good days
players will play like two or three
hundred points above their actual
strength
on bad days they'll play like a few
hundred points below their strength
so it's about finding ways to
kind of
find your your peak mental form
imagine
yeah tea is probably
a better choice than other beverages
okay so
this is a game that we played two months
ago
we went into the same line ah this game
i took on d4
i missed knight c2
did i pre-move that i did
oh that's so funny
i wonder if i have a clip of that game
so i'll go for this line
oh queen oh
i pre-moved the wrong thing
i was not expecting queen d4 i just had
knight c2 winning on the spot
i think i remember this moment where i
was expecting this
so i pre-moved queen d4
and my opponent took with the queen
but the point yeah so the point is after
here here
trade this is what i was calculating
originally
but
um yeah we didn't go into that at least
in the game that we just played
if we did
i think white is doing just
quite well win c7 up a piece
so
somehow i've still won this game though
ah because i won the rook and then
yeah i have a vague memory of this game
i don't think it made its way to youtube
though
[Music]
oh this game was from the grand master
gary arena
grandmaster gary ran like the the themed
tournament
i have to put that on youtube